[Musique]
faut dire qu'il ya eu dans cette gestion
de crise beaucoup de dysfonctionnements
et d'incohérences et nous on fera le
boulot les élus locaux sont sur le
terrain et l'autre jour et t il son
contact direct avec la population mais
il faudrait aussi que les temps et à
tous les niveaux à commencer par le
gouvernement agissent un peu plus
promptement et en tout cas ne nous donne
pas des injonctions contradictoires
parce que ça c'est juste impossible à
faire appliquer est en tout cas on
manque de lits au manque de personnel et
je trouve
voilà que peut-être on aurait pu mieux
anticiper un coup aussi difficile c'est
surtout le décalage entre les discours
qu'ils sont tenus
et puis la réalité activement quand le
président de la république dit nous
sommes prêts et bien en réalité nous ne
le sommes pas nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui avec le même nombre de lits
de réanimation qu'au mois de mars à
pleuvoir voire peut-être un peu
au-dessous 5000 en gros en gros ça me
5000 lits en france alors que très bien
on est très très clairement on sait
qu'il va nous falloir beaucoup plus la
stratégie du gouvernement elle a échoué
sur le tester tracé isolé c'est un échec
complet
parce que s'ils attaquent la stratégie
du temps de retard permanent moi ce que
j'ai dénonce aujourd'hui c'est que le
gouvernement a toujours 15 jours de
retard sur les mesures à prendre
la réalité c'est qu'il faut poser le
débat sur l'immigration et sur le manque
de contrôles d'immigration et également
sur les mesures de rétorsion d'expulsion
de sanctions or tout cela n'est pas
évoquée dans le cadre du texte de loi
qui nous a présenté on voit bien qu'il y
a eu un laxisme sur le contrôle de
l'immigration expliqué aujourd'hui qu'il
n'y a pas de lien entre le laxisme sur
le contrôle de l'immigration le
communautarisme et le terrorisme c'est
se voiler la face
corsan mosquées salafistes qui ne sont
pas fermées on a plus de 4000 étrangers
fichier s qui sont toujours sur le
territoire donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
concrètement pour ces sujets là depuis
2015 nous avons fait 37 propositions du
loin d une centaine d'amendements
nous avons toujours été vraiment une
force de proposition et jamais le
gouvernement n'a accepté de nous suivre
il ya besoin ces moments fort cette
émotion mais au-delà de ça maintenant il
faut faire il faut un texte que le
ministre d'intérieur
le premier ministre présente un texte le
plus rapidement possible c'est ça que
nous attendons pays où la facture de la
lâcheté de la naïveté par le sang de nos
compatriotes et c'est inacceptable
un professeur aujourd'hui et tues dans
des conditions particulièrement affreuse
et après sa partie à droite et après eux
les chaînes d'information on parle de 24
heures sur 24 les gouvernements fondé du
successifs font des déclarations
martiales et après le soufflé retombe et
on ne gagnera pas comme ça pour bien
accueillir ceux qui méritent d'être en
france et qui sont protégés par la
france il faut bien expulser ceux qui
n'ont rien à y faire mais simplement
depuis trois ans pourquoi on n'a rien
fait depuis 2015
j'ai compté ce matin nous avons déposé
30 cette proposition de loi pour lutter
contre le terrorisme au nom du groupe
des républicains on bat tous les records
en matière d'immigration 2019
c'est l'année historique d'entrer de
façon légale d'étrangers en france sur
les expulsions il faut agir
aujourd'hui la demande d'asile diminue
partout en europe sauf en france et nous
avons tous les déboutés du droit d'asile
qui arrivent en france qu on a une forme
de bien pensants ce qui a pendant des
années
couvert ce débat qui sous couvert de
lutte contre le racisme sous couvert de
la protection d'une forme d'échec de
l'intégration a voulu écarter ce débat
de gens presque trois ans pour faire le
discours combien de temps pour faire la
loi remet à un problème ac et finalement
assez simple c'est qu'on a une société
qui est gangréné par cette pression
permanente de l'islamisme qui commence
très tôt et qui finit même
très tard en fonction des âges je le dis
la république est en danger
elle est en danger aussi de nos
renoncements nous pensons qu'il
suffirait de manifester de nous
rassembler maintenant il faut agir
elle lutte contre l'islamisme radical ça
peut pas être la liste de trois jours
après un attentat
c'est une lutte constante de tous les
instants qui va durer plusieurs années
il faut jamais relâcher jamais et avoir
une volonté politique à toute épreuve ce
que j'attendais même macron ça n'est pas
des discours il en a fait tellement
discours je pense qu'on en a marre il
français aussi on en marre de ce
président des démos du blabla et des
discours
je crois que nous ne pouvons plus de cet
empilement de stratégie qui se
juxtaposent les unes aux autres sans que
jamais rien ne soit mis en oeuvre
concrètement
[Musique]